hey everyone I'm Abbi sharp welcome to a
DS kitchen the weather is getting warmer
so today we are going on a little field
trip outdoors for an impromptu picnic
picnics make fantastic warm weather Day
ideas because they cost you penis to put
together you get full control over the
menu and they feel pretty darn romantic
but no matter who your picnic companions
are you want to make sure to pack that
alfresco meal cleanly safely and most
importantly with delicious easy to eat
food check out my top three favorite
healthy picnic perfect recipes first up
my middle-eastern inspired mason jar
salad mason jar salads are great picnic
foods but there's a formula for
assembling this right the first
ingredient is the salad dressing which
is equal parts lemon juice and olive oil
and escort each of Dijon mustard and
honey with salt and pepper to taste next
are your hard veggies so for me that's
red pepper and cucumber next is your
greens beans or pasta so I'm using
chickpeas and a little quinoa next up is
cheese or protein so that's your meats
and tofu and all that good stuff I'm
using feta cheese here your next layer
is your softer veggies or fruits so
things like avocados berries and
tomatoes I love Tomatoes so I'm adding
those and lots of olives as well the
next layer are your nuts and seeds so
I'm adding some sunflower seeds and a
little bit of zatar which is a Middle
Eastern spice and your last layer are
those delicate greens so I'm using
spinach just super light and healthy
my second recipe is my lightened up
chicken and fig sandwich the first step
is to hollow out the bread on each side
to remove a chunk of the excess carbs
this means more room for fillings anyway
I then lay down a bed of spinach top it
off some roasted chicken breast with the
skin removed add some sliced ripe fix
dot the top with a little creamy goat
cheese and I finish with a sweet and
sticky balsamic drizzle and finally
because every good picnic needs a little
boozy treat let's make my tea infused
vodka lemonade for this recipe my go-to
is v borova pure polish vodka
affectionately nicknamed libo this is a
great vodka for those of you with celiac
or gluten intolerance because not only
is it a hundred percent GMO free it's
also naturally gluten free so I mixed
together a 750 milliliter bottle of vivo
vodka with one black tea bag and let it
sit for at least 3 hours to make the
lemonade I mix a half a cup of honey
with a cup of water in a saucepan and
simmer until dissolved then I fill a
large pitcher with 3 cups of ice-cold
water and mix in one cup of freshly
squeezed lemon juice and the dissolved
honey mixture finally I stir together an
ounce of tea vodka with my fresh
lemonade and add in some lemon slices to
a few pretty mason jars
so now ready to pack this bad boy up I
like using eco-friendly products like
these washable cloth napkins and cutlery
you'll also need some picnic blankets
some bug spray sunscreen because
sunburns are not cute colorful straws
she looks sophisticated while day
drinking and this reusable water ball
that I've frozen into an ice pack this
makes sure my food stays cool and stay
flat still frozen and then when it thaws
out I've got an icy cool drink to keep
me hydrated while I drink vodka outside
thanks so much for watching for more
great ways to get inspired for summer
entertaining be sure to subscribe to my
channel and I'll see you next time on
Abbey's kitchen well let's be honest
with warm weather in the forecast
throwback Thursday has become all about
last year's boastful barbecues and
College weekends yeah you can say we're
pretty excited so today I'm going to
show you my top tips for making
delicious locale cocktails as well as
three ears this tool recipes that'll
have a feeling great and having fun all
summer long